now you can't do much about needing the
screen on all the time but you can
control your applications network usage
pattern it's important to understand
that in terms of power consumption the
pattern of network usage is at least as
important as a total amount of data
transferred there are definite anti
patterns to network usage it turns out
that the cellular radio is designed to
switch to a low-power idle mode when not
in use to conserve battery life let's
take a look at the different states the
radio can be in the cellular radio has
something called the radio resource
controller or RRC it's kind of like a
traffic controller for the radio we
start out in the idle state and when we
make an initial request it takes around
100 milliseconds for us to get connected
and into the active state once we're
there of course we can make as many
requests as we want and stay active once
we're in the active state though if we
don't make a request for about a tenth
of a second we drop into a short sleep
mode which uses less power but it'll
take us up to 50 milliseconds in order
to get back into active if we make a
request then if we don't make any
requests for another 100 milliseconds we
drop into a long sleep mode again we can
get back to active in under 50
milliseconds but if we don't make any
requests for about 10 seconds we drop
all the way back down to idle which will
of course take us longer to get back
into active from the critical part about
this of course is that each one of these
states has a different power consumption
profile idle of course takes the least
power active takes the most short sleep
in long sleep both take and in between
but certainly more than idle so it's
important for us to leave the connection
idle as often as possible and try not to
spend too much time cycling back and
forth between sleep and active